لنطلع على الوضع في شمال غزه ينضم الينا
من تل زعتر شرق مخيم جباليه مراسل الجزيره
انس الشريف انس اطلعنا على مشاهدتك
اليوم نحن الان تمكنا من الوصول لهذه
المنطقه هنا شرق جباليا بالتحديد شرق تل
الزعتر هذه المنطقه التي دمرها الاحتلال
اثناء التقدم البري هنا في هذه المنطقه
هنا كانت المعارك بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال كما نشاهد هنا في هذه
الصوره من خلف مستوطنات غلاف غزه مستوطنه
الدوت ومستوطن مكسيم ايضا هنا بالقرب من
الحدود الشرقيه لجبال ايضا هنا في هذه
الساحه كما نشاهد هنا كانت تتمركز قوات
الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال وايضا على
المباني التي امامنا ايضا كانت تتمركز
قناصه الاحتلال هنا الان انسحاب كامل لهذه
القوات من المناطق الشرقيه لمخيم جباليا
من هذا المكان ايضا كما نشاهد هنا في هذه
المنطقه كانت المعارك بين قوات الاحتلال
والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وايضا قامت قوات الاحتلال
بتدمير جميع المباني وجميع المنازل في هذا
المكان امامنا ايضا احد المساجد التي دمرت
نتيجه هذا القصف والمعارك التي ارت بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال ايضا
على جانب اخر
هناك اشتباكات متواصله منذ الصباح في بيت
لاهيه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال ونسمع بشكل متواصل صوت هذه
الاشتباكات من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال ومدفعيه الاحتلال لم تتوقف
من خلال اطلاق قذائفها بشكل متواصل على
منازل المواطنين شمال بيت
لاهيه
اه سنعود اليك اذا انس الشريف اي لنطلع
اكثر ربما نتمكن معك
من رصد هذا الدمار الكبير في مخيم جباليه
كما رصدناه معك في الواقع في ايام سابقه